an uneasy mood has settled over Baghdad
scarred by decades of intermittent war
people in Iraq's capital know the eerie
suspense that precedes one in coffee
shops old and young alike worried about
being caught in the middle as the u.s.
and Iran threatened further escalation
we don't want the battle to come to our
country they want to start a war they
want to settle accounts but we're the
ones who lose young men lose money lose
infrastructure we won't benefit from
this people here are still in shock over
the u.s. strike that assassinated
Iranian general Qasem Soleimani near
Baghdad Airport growing threats of
retaliation from Iran and its allies in
Iraq adding insult to injury
President Donald Trump threatened on
Sunday to impose far-reaching sanctions
on Iraq if the Iraqi government
responded by expelling US troops for
wasan such rhetoric brings back painful
memories from the Saddam era when the UN
Security Council imposed a crippling
trade embargo nakisha Bob for us as
young people we've lived through the
sanctions during our childhood we don't
want to face the same thing again we
want to build the country instead the
country now risks sliding backwards the
unfolding crisis between the u.s. and
Iran has shifted attention away from
Iraq's month-long protest movement
demanding far-reaching political reform
and an end to Iranian interference in
Iraq since the manis assassination
demonstrators have been attacked at
least twice by pro-iranian crowds their
worst fear however is losing their cause
as the island mujeeb people people are
afraid they are afraid of the strikes
that happened and they fear that
something will happen inside Tahrir to
end these demonstrations demonstrators
are divided over the Parliament's
non-binding decision on Sunday to expel
foreign troops some support the motion
calling the US strike a violation of
Iraqi sovereignty we want Iraq to be an
independent country a country that
thinks and decides and makes its own
decisions without any intervention by
outside forces while others see the
presence of American troops as
necessary counterbalance to Iranian
influence I am against the Parliament's
decision to expel the troops give me an
alternative for the American troops who
will protect me an alternative to
protect these people they are all
parties in militias either I have a
party to protect me or I will die
Kurdish and Sunni parties boycotted
Sunday's Parliament vote carried by the
main Shia bloc's it's a sign that Iraq's
leadership is once again split along
sectarian lines rather than United by
national interest as divisions within
Iraq deepen over how the government
should respond to the escalating crisis
between the u.s. and Iran many Iraqis
are worried that they will once again be
dragged into a war they did not choose
their demands for a better future are
now overshadowed by fear and not to
distant memories of conflict and
hardship